les chefs
[Musique]
m
je pense que tout le monde adore danser
danser quelque chose de complètement
viscérale et chacun à sa façon de
s'exprimer
le but était pas forcément d'en faire
des danseurs professionnels dans la
semaine mais de leur communiquer cette
joie que j'ai je ressent personnellement
de penser et que et que beaucoup
d'enfants ont par toulon la chance de
pratiquer comme une activité marie
créatives on va dire mais aussi
artistique et pas de me sente et de
l'amener là où les enfants ayant
nettement accès
la danse classique en l'occurrence
apporte aussi beaucoup de rigueur ce qui
est intéressant pour la vie entassons
général pour leur vie d'enfant et pour
leur future vie d'adulte ça apprend
aussi à se présenter d'une certaine
manière toute cette posture qu'on
acquiert du dos droit de la tête haute
et tout ça peut-être que on peut avoir
l'impression que l'art c'est quelque
chose de superflu que c'est quand tout
le reste va bien et je pense qu'au
contraire c'est ce qui permet de se
sortir
mentalement de tous ces soucis des
choses qui vont pas des contraintes des
difficultés de la vie et donc je pense
c'est pour ça que c'est capital
d'apporter ça
à but éducatif
[Musique]
c'est leur donner un moment de vie
d'enfant justement dont il manque
peut-être parfois dans ces contextes un
petit peu difficile
beaucoup vivent dans des familles à ses
nombreuses dans des endroits assez
restreint je pense qu'il manque des
espaces personnels assez cruellement et
à l'école ils sont évidemment très
nombreux donc ce ne serait ce qu'à un
moment d'espacement talent personnel
mais se concentre sur quelque chose qui
n'a rien à voir avec des contraintes du
quotidien qui sont juste de tendre son
pied de lever sa jambe et ça c'est un
challenge personnel
et c'est un moment de
j'imagine d'épanouissement
[Musique]
oui finalement j'y suis allé une semaine
et c'était super et on a passé un bon
moment et tout mais bon une semaine
c'est rien et c'était une semaine qui
j'espère et épanouissante mais ça va pas
changer l'envié donc maintenant j'ai
envie de faire plus
j'ai envie de pouvoir évidemment si je
peux faire jouer des contacts et faire
profiter aux gens de la situation qu'on
a et deux de mes connexions dans le
monde de la danse ce serait
pour celles qui souhaitent en faire leur
métier mensuellement ça serait ce serait
génial qu'on puisse aller plus loin
toute façon je me suis attaché
maintenant jeu mais je vais retourner